oui
à l'est de la nationale 10 se reflétant
dans l'adour se présente dax avec ses 21
mille habitants elle constitue la
sous-préfecture du département ainsi que
le siège de l'évêché des longues
raconter l'histoire de la ville serait
bien long car elle s'enorgueillit d'un
passé riche et glorieux notons
simplement cette anecdote qui a fait de
dax une station thermale réputée un
légionnaire de jules césar possédait un
chien si perclus de rhumatismes qu'il
décida de le noyer dans l'adour la bête
réussit à gagner le rivage sont l'ua
dans la bouteille est du ruisseau qui
s'écoulait de la fontaine chaude mais
sont sortis quelques jours après
complètement guéri la nouvelle parvint à
rome et au fil des années les curistes
devenait plus nombreux dax avait trouvé
sa vocation
la ville de dax est traditionnellement
par vocation et une station thermale
chacun le sait vous êtes dur est ici
devant l'un des hôtels de la société
vous avez pu voir les établissements
thermaux et vous savez que à dax c'est
le trim est le rhumatisme et
essentiellement est soigné je dois dire
avec fruits c'est la vérité et je ne
vais pas cette réflexion par
complaisance le maire je le dis à
pleurer deux fois parce que c'est vrai
pour guérir le curiste suit un régime
difficile les traitements venance 5h le
matin et dure trois semaines donc
après avoir subi pendant un quart
d'heure à la température de 38 degrés
son bain de boue le curiste émis dans
une cabine de sudation où il reste 15 à
20 minutes
la fatigue est importante et il faut que
son corps revienne à une température
normale
il reste pour cela pendant près de deux
heures dans une salle de relaxation le
curiste se dirige ensuite vers la
piscine où l'eau est à 37 degrés dans
l'une il subi un massage kilos durant un
quart d'heure à l'aide d'un jet d'une
pression de 3 kg 500 dans l'autre
piscine alors il fait des mouvements
pour se rééduquer
parallèlement les établissements
thermaux traite les accidentés du
travail
les traumatiser de la route dans cet
établissement on compte actuellement 400
curistes qui une fois leur traitement
terminé iront se reposer dans un des
nombreux jardins de la ville les efforts
qu'elle fait sont d'ailleurs très grand
et on compte beaucoup sur l'avenir
l'internât l'isthme actuellement est en
train de se transformer sur dax du fait
que nous avons
une particularité sur la ville au point
de vue thermale ce que nous avons
plusieurs établissements thermaux
jusqu'à maintenant chaque établissement
thermal aller rechercher la boue dans
les différents endroits sur les barthes
de l'adour
il y a maintenant une transformation
c'est que les bassins de culture de la
boue puisque la boue doit être doit être
mise dans un bassin d'une culture
pendant un certain nombre de mois va
être pris par la ville et ensuite cette
boue sera vendu aux établissements
thermaux de manière à ce que l'on est
une bouée absolument impeccable au point
de vue du traitement
autre visage autre style dax en fait
c'est une des nombreuses distractions
que peut offrir le curiste ou encore le
tourisme les fêtes durent huit jours à
dax et provoque chez tous enthousiasmés
et joie il faut bien avouer aussi que
c'est une source supplémentaire de
fatigue pour celui qui veut profiter de
la ville dans ce domaine aussi fait de
gros efforts car c'est pour elle sa
deuxième source essentielle de richesse
comme chaque année très bien nous
cherchons à faire plaisir à tous c'est à
dire qu'il y à des spectacles de grande
qualité comme tous ceux qui sont donnés
aux arènes
mais ces spectacles étant relativement
onéreux nous pensons à tous ceux qui ne
peuvent pas s'offrir ces réjouissances
et c'est la raison pour laquelle et nous
commençons même par ceux là nous donnons
tous les jours des spectacles gratuits
et des spectacles
je ne sais pas si vous avez vu mais qui
sont capables de satisfaire des gens
exigeants et qui paieraient leur place
active ou à de la tradition soit gardé
la sueur mais sûrement
d'autant que tout le monde y est
d'intéresser tout le monde
chacun vit sa vie de chacun vis est bête
et vous pouvez constater qu'il y à
beaucoup d'animations et que vraiment
dax prend conscience d'elle-même tout à
fait au moment de ces fêtes patronales
c'est pourquoi ceci correspond à un
sentiment quelque chose de spontané et
je pense que les fêtes patronales de
dates ne sont pas près de s'éteindre et
de diminuer d'intensité
les arènes était comble mardi penser on
affichait el cordobès de quoi faire
vibrer le coeur des profanes qui
viennent de très loin pour découvrir les
plus grands matadors espagnols
thermalisme tourisme
les deux principales richesses de gaz la
conclusion à ce sujet reste directeur de
l'office du tourisme et ne manque pas de
piment au point de vue touristique
nous sommes en train de relancer le
tourisme
parce que jusqu'à maintenant la ville
s'occupait principalement de une
thermalisme
or maintenant nous pensons que au point
de vue touristique
il faut se lancer surtout que nous
sommes quand même dans une ville qui est
située à 20 km de la nationale 10 donc
une halte possible au cours du trajet
des personnes qui vont soit sur la côte
basque soit en espagne ce qui est quand
même important et d'autre part je pense
que c'est un centre si vous voulez où le
touriste peut venir peut s'installer à
peu prendre une chambre surtout que nous
avons le nombreux hôtels nous entendons
à peu près 60 actuellement opel nous
avons énormément de meublés donc il est
possible pour le touriste de s'installer
et ensuite de rayonner dans les environs
ce qui je crois est très important